and we are at capacity tonight here at
the opulent Tostito Center 50 000 fans
are ready to binge drink for a couple of
hours I tell you what I can't wait hi
I'm grown Manchester Rica and I'm grown
man Bob desantio that's right Bob and we
have both made careers watching adult
men play a simple child's game all while
being paid more than the president okay
chick and it seems as though the
millionaires are ready to play their
game so we can stop stalling with the
Mindless check and the Rhinos been the
ball into play and the alleged rapist
passes the Big Orange ball to the sweaty
legal giant hey uh
easily puts the ball into the basket
making it look easy which if you're
seven feet tall it is he made about
eight thousand dollars while he was
doing it now the power Falcons are
bringing the ball into play the high
school dropout inbound to the convicted
spousal abuser he slashes through all of
the drug addict stops the ball after the
genetic freak and boom quackalacka two
points from downtown Oscar placas Bingo
time nonsense
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you okay I'm great Bob
doing finish to an incredible game
tonight with Charlie Sanders winning the
game in literally the last second uh
unbelievable truly spectacular Charlie
Sanders how does it feel hey y'all want
to say something to everybody watching
yo you can do anything anything's
possible The World is Yours Charlie did
you think that that game was gonna end
that way tonight yo there are no limits
all right you can swim across here
learning you can jump real high and
touch the moon fantastic Charlie Sanders
fresh off of his uh Victory uh it just
feels like he's ready to touch the Moon
on anybody can fly if you believe in
yourself the way I believe in myself
tonight you will fly and what's next for
Charlie Sanders and the orange twins you
can actually fly no no not well not
literally yes yes literally kids young
kids I want you to go up on your roofs
right now wait what fly into the night
sky okay people will see you flying and
you can do anything you can do anything
okay well we we just want to remind the
kids that of course you cannot actually
fly kids oh y'all screw that negativity
man hey boys and girls ages 8 through
12. yo don't let nobody ever tell you
what you can and cannot do all them
pre-teen children out there listen to
Mom voice you are Immortal okay well
obviously we understand that Charlie is
super excited right now and that no one
is actually Immortal no
it is you can turn yourself into a car
and have a friend drive you onto the
freeway okay nope well that's just a
metaphor again we don't have the power
of childish innocence
on your back and make a beat along for
the next ramp to the freeway y'all okay
don't do it freeway he's speaking figure
it out once you get there ain't nothing
figurative about this you will turn into
a robot first and foremost I just want
to say the 12 families who lost children
sorry
my statements were irresponsible
have subsequently looked up the times
literally and metaphorically and found
that
whereas I was not incorrect they did not
mean what I thought they had meant
[Music]
it's November you gotta get out and vote
it's all about democracy y'all your boat
gets counted with the rest of the boats
in the country and they get sent off to
the Electoral College what's that the
Electoral College are a bunch of
officials who do the voting for us so in
case we elect the wrong person they can
fix their shoes
hold up
who the hell are these people well no
one knows for sure but whoever they is
they the folks who actually do the real
voting after we do our pretend vote yeah
you're telling me our votes don't matter
our votes are like suggestions so this
November we should yeah dunk the vote
welcome back we're here talking with
All-Star shooting guard Charlie Sanders
about his amazing career now Charlie you
grew up in a tough neighborhood didn't
you that's right
drugs violence
my whole life I had to deal with
adversity and that continued when you
went on to the pros that's right you
know fines injuries everything no matter
how big a star I am
I'm always going to be dealing with
adversity adversity Johnson what's your
take on this I don't know girl
[Music]
always wherever we go it's
come on no don't don't drink my water
don't drink my water at first you leave
me some leave me a sip leave me a sip
damn come on man this
he doesn't I'm sorry
no he doesn't pick up social cues
what here we
go
[Applause]
come on are you okay no police say late
last night they apprehended Rodney
gullivand and found a gun and narcotics
in his truck he was charged with
possession and assault on his fiancee
and she is in the hospital recovering
tonight
meanwhile another woman was sexually
assaulted by Benjamin Brader of
Indianapolis the unidentified woman
suffered a broken rib and a split lip
she's in stable condition tonight
well that's it for sports Chuck
welcome to metal world news our top
story a professional athlete should
never Post online looking for people to
live action role-play Hunger Games with
them I'm sorry Gerard Kaylee and Zach
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday August microwave with you
I'm Metta World Peace good night
welcome to Meadow world news our top
story why are people always trying to
steal my magic
in other news cat litter can be used to
blind people when fighting interesting I
didn't know that
well that wraps up Metta World news for
this Wednesday February biscuit fountain
drink I'm Meadow World Peace good night
welcome to Metta World News in sports
I'd rather eat my hand than to have my
penis cut off I really have to believe
someone was going to cut it off but if I
did I can definitely eat my hand I know
because I had a dream where I did it it
was horrible I ate my whole hand
now that's what you call rhetoric well
that wraps up Meadow world news for this
Wednesday April hurricane Slipknot I met
a world peace good night
[Music]
welcome to metal world news in fashion
if you woke up and there was a four inch
miniature human standing on your chest
would you swat them off I was really
challenged by this question I would hope
that I had engaged them in conversation
but in reality I think I ought to be
scared of them and SWAT them away which
would probably kill them
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday October noise canceling
octagon Tire I met a world peace good
night
[Music]
did I fulfill my contract Satan
[Music]
welcome to metal world news
I wish there was a Genie in here
what's up middle world news for this
Wednesday March hybrid ice rink I met a
world peace good night hey Jim where's
that Genie
[Music]
welcome to metal world news our top
story ninja costumes don't come in size
XXX which is discriminatory against
enormous assassins
you know what forget about the
teleprompter
I need to speak from the heart
well that wraps up Metta World news for
this Wednesday May staple gun hairbrush
I'm mad at World Peace good night
[Music]
welcome to metal world news our top
story the pope is thinking of moving out
the Vatican so feral cats can live there
now let's go to homemaker's corner with
Meadow World Peace
thank you mother you need five plastic
grocery bags to make an effective
parachute
thanks meta and you will die if you try
that
well that wraps up Metta World news for
this Wednesday November Morning Star
cocktail neck I'm Metta World Peace good
night
welcome to metal world news in science
news it is impossible to knock yourself
out with your own fist
let's not fall behind America
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday biscuit biscuit biscuit
I'm Metta World Peace good night
[Music]
you win fish I'm the one in the aquarium
[Music]